Hello Freak bitches.
Whenever I'm at the UFC and
somebody gets kicked in the face,
I just always,
I just think about how disappointed I
be if I got kicked in the face of it,
what did I do?
Am I alive?
Why somebody kicking me in the face?
Even especially,
I mean you never been kicked in the
face which has been kicked in the face.
Especially like that's why I'm glad I
didn't fight that guy and I'm glad I
don't.
I don't,
you know,
put myself in situations where I've got
to fight a stranger because you never
know where.
I'm just,
if I was to be fighting,
I'm trying to throw hands poorly,
but if somebody just kicked
me in the face and I'm like,
oh,
I didn't,
I didn't know you were going to do that.
This Donald Cerrone combination.
God Damn,
that's beautiful.
Left high kick,
boom.
Turn his back.
That is Matrix Shit.
Donald Cerrone lives
in the fucking Matrix,
dude,
right now.
All of a sudden he's coming
on the podcast next week.
Jamie,
he's here on next Tuesday.
I'm going to fucking convince him.
Live on the Internet.
Don't drop down from one 70
and one 70 is a fucking wizard.
Who the hell is stopping
and Rick story like this?
Oh Man.
Donald Cerrone is a fucking wizard.
He's a wizard at one 70.
If it felt it felt kind
of barbaric or archaic,
but when you have money on somebody and
they're beating the shit out of somebody
else and you're winning,
it's a different type of emotion.
When he went Serone started
fucking that dude up,
I stood up like
you were in there with them.
I was in there in there with him
for a couple thousand dollars.
Hell yeah.
I was with him.
I was in Flint.
Fucking,
I appreciate your loyalty.
First of all,
it's both on it and Donald Ronnie Dope.
And then,
uh,
Johnson,
I bet on Johnson right
before the fight started.
I was like,
Huh,
what would the aunt,
he was minus two 50.
So
pretty reasonable considering how hard
and the one,
it's so fast.
I got on it.
We think it's,
somebody told me I have to research it.
Please do.
Was that the fastest knockout in the
history of the light heavyweight division?
It was 13 seconds or something
longer to place my bet.
He hit so hard.
That happened so fast.
It was like he hit so hard.
It happens so quick.
When Glover started pressuring him,
like what?
When I score a fight or
rather a commentator fight
when I watch something like
that.
And I'm like,
okay,
what can glow overdue
and what can rumble too?
We know rumble has
awesome stand up skills.
We know we had a college
wrestling background.
We know he's a really powerful and
he's probably the hardest hit are ever.
So what can glow over do?
He's really technical.
He can survive a storm.
Maybe he could take him down.
Maybe he can get them into deep water.
So he starts out super aggressive.
Bob and,
and we even Tyson style and one
haymaker one haymaker uppercut.
So Start Brian Jimmo third.
Wow.
Seven seconds.
Goddamn Brian Chimo uh,
rest in peace.
Ryan Gmo.
He just died recently.
I run over by a car and Canada.
Oh Shit.
That's James Irvin Sandman.
Eight seconds.
Who did he fight?
And then John's rumbled jobs that gamble.
It's a gamble on that.
And then have it happen that fast.
That's like fucking crabs.
They should put like a 32nd over
under on summer rumbles fights does is
literally a 32nd because
he's so scary right now.
He's so scary.
He hits guys in a totally different way.
It's like he knows something that nobody
knows about how to hit people because
this dude,
what was that guy's record?
34 25 Oh four Alexander.
Eight seconds.
That's right.
What was the guy,
Johnson faults record?
Was it 25 like he was an elite fighter.
Oh,
clover is beyond elite.
Glover's fought for the title.
He had a five round fight with Jon Jones.
Went to the distance.
Yeah,
so it's one of the best
fighters in the world.
Glover's excellent desk.
Go crazy.
They got gotten 13 seconds.
You don't want it.
It is,
man.
There's the human frame.
You know,
like the skull,
the brain,
the neck can only take so much.
It just can only take so much.
Yeah,
and most people can't hit that bell.
You know that bell when you go to the
carnival and he slammed down on that bell
and the little thing goes up and
most people can't make that thing.
Dang.
In this world for Rumble Johnson,
he can make that thing ding
every time with is open barrage.
Yeah.
With his first,
you know,
name the number 200 punches and kicks,
whatever it is,
he can knock you the fuck out.
The question with a guy like that is
if he gets past that 200 number and the
opponent is still there,
can he make it through it?
And that's what happened
in the Cormier fight.
It's like rumble hit core me with
everything but the kitchen sink.
But Cohlmia is so fucking tough.
He's so tough from being in a world
class Olympic wrestler from a guy who
competed all over the world.
He's just got this,
this is like a level of toughness that
you can't recreate and he takes a big
bomb but figures out how
to scramble and survive.
Yeah.
And so he makes it into,
um,
what,
what rounded core may submit rumble.
See the thing about a guy like rumble
though is you could submit them once,
but once he figures out what you did
and he remembers how much it sucked when
you did that to him,
can you do it again?
And if you can't do it again,
what if he can figure out
how to keep it standing?
Yeah.
What if he could figure out how to keep
hitting you with those barrages of heavy
bones common flying at you
with perfect technique.
He hit us so fucking hard,
man.
What third round?
Well,
Cormy took them into deep water,
man.
Okay.
[inaudible].